let me sneak up to the questions of
consciousness a little further
so we usually um
relate suffering to consciousness
so the capacity to suffer
i think to me that's a really strong
sign of consciousness
is a thing that can suffer
how how is that useful
suffering
and like in your model where you just
described which is indexing of memories
and
what is the coherence with the
perception
uh with this predictive thing that's
going on the perception
how how does suffering relate to any of
that
you know the higher level suffering that
humans do
basically pain is a reinforcement signal
it pain uh is a signal that one part of
your brain sends to another part of your
brain or an abstract sense part of your
mind sends to another part of the mind
to regulate its behavior to tell it the
behavior that you're currently
exhibiting should be improved and this
is the signal that i tell you uh
to move away from what you're currently
doing and push into a different
direction so pain gives you a
part of you an impulse to do something
differently
but sometimes this doesn't work because
for the training part of your brain is
talking to the wrong region
or because it has the wrong model of the
relationships in the world maybe you're
mismodeling yourself or you're
mismodding the relationship of yourself
to the world or you're mismodding the
dynamics of the world so you're trying
to improve something that cannot be
improved by generating more pain
but the system doesn't have any
alternative
so the uh it doesn't get better what do
you do if something doesn't get better
and you want it to get better you
increase the strength of the signal and
then the signal becomes chronic when it
becomes permanent without a change
inside this is what we call suffering
and
the purpose of consciousness is to deal
with contradictions with things that
cannot be resolved
the purpose of consciousness i think is
similar to a conductor in an orchestra
when everything works well the orchestra
doesn't need much of a conductor as long
as it's coherent but when there is a
lack of coherence or something is
consistently producing disharmony and
mismatches then the conductor becomes
alert and interacts with it so suffering
attracts the activity of our
consciousness and the purpose of that is
ideally that we bring new layers online
new layers of modeling that
are able to create a model of the
dysregulation so we can deal with it
and this means that we typically get
higher level consciousness so to speak
right we get some consciousness above
our pay grade maybe if we have some
suffering early in our life most of the
interesting people had trauma early on
in their childhood and trauma means that
you are suffering an injury for which
the system is not prepared
which it cannot deal with which it
cannot insulate itself from so something
breaks
and this means that the behavior of the
system is permanently
disturbed in a way that uh some mismatch
exists now in the regulation that just
by following your impulses by following
the pain and the direction that it hurts
the situation doesn't improve but get
worse
and so what needs to happen is that you
grow up
yeah that and that's part that is grown
up is able to deal with the part that is
stuck in this earlier phase yeah so it
leads to growth adding extra layers to
okay to your cognition uh
let me ask you then because i gotta
stick on suffering
the ethics of the whole thing
so not our consciousness but the
consciousness of others you've uh
uh tweeted one of my biggest fears
is that insects could be conscious
the amount of suffering on earth would
be unthinkable
so
when we think of other conscious beings
is suffering
a property of consciousness
that we're most concerned about
so
i'm still thinking about robots
how to make sense of other non-human
things
that appear to have
the depth of experience that humans have
and to me
that means consciousness and the darkest
side of that which is suffering the
capacity to suffer
and so i start thinking
how much responsibility do we have for
those other conscious beings
that's where the um
the definition of consciousness becomes
most urgent like having to come up with
a definition of consciousness becomes
most urgent
is
who should we and should we not be
torturing
there's no general answer to this was
jinger's kind doing anything wrong
it depends right on how you look at it
well he
he drew he drew a line somewhere
where this is us and that's them it's
the circle of empathy
it's like these
you don't have to use the word
consciousness but
these are the things that matter to me
if they suffer or not and these are the
things that don't matter yeah but men
when one of his commanders failed him he
uh broke his spine and let him die
in a horrible way and uh so
in some sense i think he was indifferent
to suffering
or he was not different in the sense
that he didn't
see it as useful if he inflicted
suffering
but he did not see it as something that
had to be avoided that was not the goal
the question was how can i use suffering
and the infliction of suffering to reach
my goals from his perspective
i i see so like different societies
throughout history put different value
on
different individuals different psyches
but also even the uh the objective of
avoiding suffering like some societies
probably i mean this is where like
religious belief really helps
that
that afterlife
that doesn't matter that you suffer or
die what matters is you suffer honorably
right so that you enter the afterlife
it seems to be superstitious to me
basically believes that
asserts things uh for which no evidence
exists
are incompatible with sound epistemology
and i don't think that religion has to
be superstitious otherwise it should be
condemned in all cases you're somebody
who's saying we live in a dream world we
have zero evidence for anything so
that's not the case
there are limits to what languages can
be constructed mathematics brings solid
evidence for its own structure and once
we
have some idea of what languages exist
and how a system can learn and what
learning itself is in the first place
and so on we can
begin to
realize that our intuitions that we are
able to learn about the regularities of
the world and minimize the appraisal and
understand the nature of our own agency
to some degree of abstraction that's not
an illusion so useful approximation just
because we live in a dream world doesn't
mean mathematics can
uh give us a
consistent glimpse of
physical of objective reality we can
basically distinguish useful encodings
from useless encodings and when we
apply our truth seeking to the world we
know we usually cannot find out whether
a certain thing is true
what we typically do is we take the
state vector of the universe separated
into separate objects that interact with
each other so interfaces and this
distinction that we are making is not
completely arbitrary it's done to
optimize the compression that we can
apply to our models of the universe so
we can predict what's happening with our
limited resources in this sense is not
arbitrary but the separation of the
world into objects that are somehow
discrete and interacting with each other
is not the true reality right the
boundaries between the objects are
projected into the world not arbitrarily
projected but still
it's only an approximation of what's
actually the case
and we sometimes notice that we run into
contradictions when we try to understand
high-level things like economic aspects
of the world and so on or political
aspects or psychological aspects where
we make simplifications and the objects
that we are using to separate the world
are just one of many possible
projections of what's going on
and so it's not in this postmodernist
sense completely arbitrary and you're
free to pick what you want or dismiss
what you don't like because it's all
stories no that's not true you have to
show for every model of how well it
predicts the world so the confidence
that you should have in the entities of
your models
should correspond to the evidence that
you have
you